(people chattering)
- Oh, oh, oh!
I'm turned on by both.
- We wanted to conduct an experiment
here in this beautiful bar, where we could
actually put perceived
masculinity to the test.
So what you'll see is our
wonderful subject, Broderick,
portraying two different
versions of himself.
One that tends to be so much
more traditionally masculine
in how he conducts himself.
- The guy on the right didn't smile,
so I feel like you have this inclination
where you want to win him over.
- People like the chase.
- I would fuck the guy on the right.
I would probably be in a relationship
with the guy on the left.
- And the other one, where
he tends to be less so,
and can show a very
different side of himself.
- I feel like he's more approachable.
- Could be gay?
- [Matt] To determine
if people do tend to be
a little bit more attracted
to the traditionally masculine traits.
We can show a lot about ourselves
based on how much or how
little we're smiling.
People tend to to say that
they're really attracted
to the bad boy, which is a
little bit more of a smolder.
- This guy on the right
would let me have it!
Like, "Yeah, I'm gonna
give it to you hard."
And then this guy's sweet like
we could have a good giggle.
- This experiment is
actually really interesting
because it's not about
the differences between
masculine or feminine,
but how we're valuing that.
You could take the test
as it's going along,
and see what comes up for you.
- [Both Women] Whoa!
- I think I hate both of them.
- Nah, I'm into the one on the right.
- His dick's all out!
- Tell me about manspreading, what's that?
- I am not doing that.
- Just have your dick everywhere.
- You're just like, "Yeah, whatever."
(laughing)
- I like the guy on the left.
The way that he's
sitting up, his clothing.
- This guy might be too proper for me.
- He seems a little more at ease,
so I'm more inclined to go with the right.
- Someone might try to order a drink
and since this guy's spread
out, they can't get to 'em.
- The man on the right, I like more
because I love sweatpants.
I enjoy a good penis print.
- More of a relaxed look and presentation
based on how we're dressed
and how we're positioned
tends to be a little bit
more traditionally masculine
because it shows that
there's not been too much
thoughtfulness or effort
that's been placed in it.
- The guy on the left is
really theatrical. (chuckles)
- I can tell that he's a little bit more
feminine in his gestures,
but I find that kinda sexy.
- You're a good buddy.
You're not the type of person that I wanna
take home with me. (chuckles)
- I know what firework looks like.
You don't have to do that.
- His body language reads a lot friendlier
than the other guy.
- It was easier to just focus on Mr. Right
because he was just staring at you.
- I need that gain, that like,
"Are you interested in me?
"Aren't you?"
That's what entices me.
- Hand gestures.
I tend to use a lot of hand gestures.
From one version of Broderick,
you'll see him using his hands a lot more,
and that tends to be less
traditionally masculine
because it's opening up a little bit more
of an emotional vulnerability.
- Did you see that shot, though?
- Dude, that thing was crazy!
The whole apartment
started going wild, man.
- But did you see that shot last night?
- Dude, that thing was crazy, man.
The whole apartment went
wild, yo. (laughing)
- Him on the right.
- Yeah, that was quick.
(laughing)
- How come?
- His voice was deeper.
- I get the juxtaposition,
but that was too slow.
- He was able to just say
something, and it mattered.
- I always wished that
I had that smooth voice.
Just more chill and just more quiet.
- I think I would be drawn to find
the person with the lower voice
than the guy with the high, squeaky voice.
- [Matt] How come?
- I grew up with men
that were very machismo.
I see myself being attracted to that.
- Speech can communicate a
lot, being slower, lower.
There's something that tends to be
a little more traditionally masculine
because it doesn't
really show an openness.
- Definitely on the right.
- Yeah.
- He's way more engaged.
- So you find yourself really drawn
to the one that's gonna be locked in.
- Hell yeah!
- [Woman] Yeah.
- He's leaning in a little
bit, that's endearing.
- [Man] He looked like he was actually
paying attention and cared.
- What do you hate about
the guy on the left?
- He's just looking at other people.
- Don't make eye contact.
Don't look at that ass.
So just that little snippet is like,
"Oh, that's sexy."
- Eye contact really
conveys a lot of intimacy
because when you're looking directly
at somebody's eyes, it's like looking
into the window of their souls.
So, there can be an emotional
connection from that.
- [Woman Wearing Hat] So what happened
between you and your ex?
(sighs)
- Well, I always felt like I was the one
loving her and caring
for her and everything,
but it seems like she wasn't happy.
She always felt like she was the one
that was calling the shots
and always doing everything right,
and she basically broke my heart.
Well, we tried to make it work...
We went out a lot, we tried
to do different things,
we tried to find the missing pieces,
but unfortunately, we just
couldn't figure it out.
- That was like Nicholas
Sparks up in here.
- I think the left was a
little bit of a turn-off
because he kept blaming her.
- [Man] I was ready to
be like, "Fuck her."
- [Woman] He just had
the answers too quickly.
- He had closure, and
in the one on the right,
there was a lot of ambiguity.
- [Man] I was like, "Just spit it out!"
- He was very internalized about it
and just seemed like he was still thinking
about it in his head.
- He is not over her because
he's still saying we, we, we,
whereas number one was like, I, I, I.
- So emotional intelligence,
or EQ, is when you have
a deeper awareness and insight
about the emotional temperature
of whatever might be going on.
We can typically think
about how traditionally,
a man is supposed to be really aggressive
and forthcoming, otherwise it's showing
an emotional awareness.
- [Woman Wearing Hat] So,
when do you wanna hang out?
- I'm free Wednesday.
Are you free? I'm free after 6.
- [Woman Wearing Hat] After 6 is good.
- Dope, I know this really
dope Italian restaurant
right down the street.
I think you're gonna like
it. You like Italian food?
- [Woman Wearing Hat] Yeah.
- Awesome, I'm sure you're gonna love it.
- Hey, I should get
your number real quick.
- [Woman Wearing Hat] Okay,
so when do you want to--
- Hey, we'll figure it out.
I'll text you.
Hey, can I get a drink for her real quick?
- What.
- Yeah, no way on the right.
- [Woman In Tank Top] Yeah.
- I'd rather have an
exact plan and footprint.
It just makes you feel like the person
cares about you.
- It's always like, "Yeah, whatever.
"We'll figure it out."
And that means that I'm
never gonna see you again.
- Shit, I feel like I'm such a slut
'cause I'd probably pick
the one on the right.
- Maybe I'm a flake, I don't know.
(chuckles)
The pressure freaks me out.
- [Woman] He knew how to play it.
It was suave.
- So there's something cool about it?
It felt cool?
- Yeah, the other guy was like,
(grunts) "Can you get out your gCal
"while we try and write
the date and time?"
- Commitment tends to be something
where we can tell a
little bit about a person,
and traditionally speaking, a man
isn't supposed to be as
committed or available
as what you would think
of as the aloof guy.
What's attractive about that?
- I don't know what the fuck
is attractive about that.
What is it?
That's something deeper rooted in me
where I'm vying for someone's attention.
I don't know. That's fucked up, man.
I don't know.
- I definitely think that gender norms
still actually influence,
though I do think
there's been an evolution
overall in terms of what that might mean
and how things have been redefined.
Some of us really exist
more in an emotional side,
some of us exist in so much
more of a rational side,
and it feels like those are two
competing forces, and when we're guided
by what society tells
us is okay and normal,
then we're gonna be shifted to one end
of the spectrum instead of being able
to have a more realized sense of ourselves
as balanced overall.
- Let the nipples fly.
(Matt laughs)
Let it breathe.
So I enjoy when men let it breathe, too.
It makes me really happy.
- Mmhmm.
(laughing)